hi
my name is jenny and today i'm going to
be trying to identify different
languages from around asia
i'm first generation american my dad is
from india and my mom is from the
philippines i've heard their languages
yeah i'm a little bit nervous because
there's literally
thousands of languages in asia my
strategy for trying to identify the
languages
is gonna be try to maybe think
what area it's gonna be it from and then
try to narrow it down from there so
let's see if you guys can beat my score
all right i'm ready to go on an auditory
journey to asia
[Music]
i have a feeling i know what this is it
sounds like japanese
i don't even know how to explain it but
it's just like the
the tones
okay now i don't think it's japanese
anymore it could be
a chinese language can you say another
like couple phrases again
oh man i'm just getting really thrown
off now um could you say
like hello my name is what your name is
and then
like i like to cook
hello
fun okay i think it's mandarin that's
that's my final answer
ah so what language were you speaking
mandarin yes good job
you grew up in taiwan right yeah in
taiwan the official language
is mandarin that's what they teach in
school but um
at home sometimes you also speak
taiwanese which is a dialect
one side of my grandparents speak
taiwanese and the other side speaks
mandarin strictly so um so i grew up
with like
by you know bilingual so what language
do you dream in
i don't know it's a good question i
definitely know that i count
in mandarin still can you teach me um
how to say bye
zaijin tai jin zai jin tai jin
zai jin jin all right
tai jin
[Laughter]
all right so so far i'm one for one and
i'm feeling pretty good about it
yes
[Music]
[Music]
i think it's a language that i don't
hear often but i do think
maybe it is still like a pretty major
language
at first i thought it sounded like
almost a mix of
like an indian language or dialect
but also it there was parts of it that
sounded similar to
chinese to me so like maybe somewhere
around those areas so like i'm thinking
maybe like thailand
or malaysia so i'm not a hundred percent
sure
but i want to guess thai the language i
was speaking
was vietnamese i was regionally close
i've heard michelle speak vietnamese on
the phone in the past but it's a much
different experience
when you're blindfolded and actually
actively listening
rather than just hearing someone in the
background on the phone did you grow up
speaking vietnamese
so i've spoken and understood vietnamese
from
a very young age basically my entire
life i generally say that i speak at a
third grade level my parents left
vietnam
in the 70s during the war and first
landed in belgium
and then came to america in the 80s san
diego specifically
so growing up i was around a lot of
people who spoke
vietnamese english spanish
and maybe even a little bit of french
what's your favorite thing about
speaking multiple languages
my favorite thing about being bilingual
is that
it gives us the ability to understand
and sort of be a part of this entirely
separate culture from our own
in a way i think that language sort of
binds us to our ancestry
and our history no matter where we end
up in the world it sort of maps out
the path that our family has taken
throughout the years
okay so so far i've got one out of two i
hope you guys aren't disappointed
michelle i do feel like i was kind of
regionally close on that last one
so i'm feeling good about the next one
don't happen say oh oh
i recognize this one in your language
can you tell me
your favorite foods
oh okay i know that one yes this one
sounds really familiar to me but even
though i don't
understand the language like i can kind
of recognize
some words here and there can you tell
me about
your family
okay i definitely think this is tagalog
all right let's see
the language i was speaking is tagalog
hey
so what are the languages do you speak
well i also speak italian
fluently i speak
kapang fangan which is the dialect that
my family
knows and speak me with sometimes
there's so many languages and dialects
in the philippines there is a 170 that i
know of
can you teach me how to say my favorite
food is
um
i totally forgot already thank you
so i've heard a lot of tagalog growing
up pretty much every holiday and also
my mom loves to talk to her sisters on
the phone very loudly so i can hear them
alright so
two out of three that's pretty good i'm
feeling good about it
yeah uh what did you have for lunch
today
tell me a little bit about your
childhood in your language
this is japanese for sure at first i
thought maybe korean
but it definitely has like the i guess
sharp-ish
kind of sounds of japanese i also
think i got a little bit of a sound of a
place she mentioned
and that sounded like tokyo to me let's
see who we've got
ah the language i was speaking was
japanese
i knew it so did you grow up bilingual
yeah yeah so my mom
um made it a point to just speak to me
in japanese as much as she could since
my dad doesn't speak japanese
and i was mostly raised in the states so
she was like the only japanese source i
would have really had
when i was really little we would spend
chunks of time in japan like if my dad
was away working
and so at one point i like forgot
english even
came back and for like two weeks the
babysitter was like
uh because i would just like be blabbing
on in japanese and she'd be like
okay okay can you teach me something in
japanese like
um how to ask for directions
or something like that so um if you're
looking for a place
you say the name of the place followed
with wa
it's kind of like saying like the cafe
is where okay
of course the first thing that comes to
mind is starbucks because they have
those everywhere in japan and they
shorten it to
stabba
and then it's ca
yeah good job okay cool great now i'll
always know where the starbucks is if i
ever go to japan
okay last thing i want to learn in
japanese is how to say goodbye
sayonara oh i knew that i feel like yeah
but everyone accents it with like funky
in english so you can learn like
sayonara
yeah exactly
very good all right
i could tell it was japanese because
japanese just sounds
so much more different than the other
languages that i heard today i feel
inspired to learn languages now they all
sound so cool
if i was to learn one maybe it would be
japanese or hindi because that would be
connected to my roots so that would be
really interesting if you guys were
playing along let me know how you did
and did you do better than me these were
only four out of the thousands of
asian languages if you speak any other
ones or there's other ones you would
want to hear let me know also
[Music]
whatever
[Music]
[Music]
nice